now if you've been following the news
recently you'll probably recall seeing
something like this in the political
coverage a treasury Source saying
there's an eye-watering black hole in
the public finances it's going to be
rough the truth is that everyone's going
to have to contribute more in tax if
we're going to maintain public services
so a lot of work yet to be done but what
is that black hole well let's go back to
First principles and look at this this
is the national debt and just looking at
it over the next few years and what
changed in the last few months well you
had the mini budget and rather than
flatlining that made the national debt
start to rise and really what's the
black hole it's all about narrowing that
Gap getting the national debt falling or
indeed flatlining rather than Rising so
we need to work out how we can fill that
particular hole so we'll bring it across
and that comes to about 70 billion
pounds a year but here's the good news
there is some good news though the
treasury doesn't really talk want to
talk about it that much which is
actually the size of the black hole
isn't Rising it's falling because of
lower debt interest costs and also on
top of that they have started the work
of filling the Gap so you had that
undoing the mini budget what Jeremy
hunted a few weeks ago that brings in
about 32 billion pounds but you still
have that Gap about 30 billion pounds
you need to find what could you do well
you could potentially up upward lift
benefits in line with earnings rather
than inflation not very good for those
who are receiving benefits but does
bring in about 5 billion pounds you can
do the same thing for pensions so get
rid of the triple lockers well you can
see we're starting to fill that Gap but
these are difficult decisions you could
spend less on investment not very good
for growth but nonetheless you could
bring in about 10 billion pounds that
way but still you haven't quite filled
it have you so you've got to go further
you've got to go for policies like maybe
more fiscal drugs so dragging more
people into paying higher rates of tax
you could abolish non-dom status that
would bring in about three billion
pounds maybe not very popular in the
sunac household or you could scrap some
of the inheritance tax relief so you can
see we're gradually getting up towards
that black hole but here's the thing the
treasury might want to go even further
than this because they like to have a
bit of Headroom so not just fill in the
back hole but have a bit of Headroom on
top so if you're going to do that you're
having to go for various different
policies like for instance reinstating
the Health and Social care Levy or doing
big spending cuts those are the kinds of
things they're talking about in the
treasury right now but it's worth just
saying the size of that black hole is
determined by how much they want to get
the national debt falling